okay today I'm going to talk to you
about distance time graphs now all of
distance time graph is is it shows you
the movement of an object as time passes
so how far it travels normally you would
be using graph paper for this because it
doesn't show up very well on the video
I'm just using plain paper for today
okay so let's have a quick look at this
let's imagine well first of all we need
to get our axes sorted because on the x
axis we always have time so this is one
second two second three second four
second so on and the y axis we always
have distance now this could be measured
in meters it could be measured in
kilometers it depends upon what we're
looking at so let's imagine we've got an
object that does this I'm just going to
draw the graph first and then we'll just
discuss it in a second
so like this okay so let's imagine this
is a person walking so at point zero
after no seconds has passed they haven't
gone anywhere that makes sense so after
one second they've traveled one meter
after two second they travel two meters
up three seconds they've traveled three
meters so whenever we see a line like
this a straight line going up like this
we know that this person is traveling at
a constant speed so this line here is a
flat line now what does that mean this
person after can we see that they've
traveled three meters as time continues
they haven't traveled any further so if
when we see a straight line on a
distance time graph like this straight
flat line this means the object is
stationary that means the object is
still because as time passes the object
doesn't go any further now what's
happening here is between seconds 8 and
10 we now again have constant speed but
this time it's much faster than before I
could tell it's faster because we've got
a steeper gradient the line is steep
than before now what I'm gonna do now is
I'm just gonna demonstrate how to use a
distance time graph to calculate the
speeds so let's imagine we're looking at
these two different sections section 1
this little portion here between seconds
will soon between 0 seconds and 3
seconds and this section here between 8
seconds and 10 seconds so there are are
two different sections that we're going
to have a quick look at now if we
remember what I'm trying to do is I'm
gonna try and see what the speed of the
person is here let's imagine there's a
person walking and what is the speed of
the person here so if we remember to
calculate speed we need to do speed
equals distance over time this is an
equation that we need to learn for your
GCSE ok speed equals distance over time
so let's imagine first of all I'm trying
to sorry I just move the paper a little
bit I'm trying to find the speed of this
first portion here now I need to see the
distance that this person has traveled
over in this put period here so distance
is up the y-axis this person has
traveled 3 meters now in what period of
time have they done that well they've
done it in 3 seconds
so to find my speed I need distance
divided by time because this allows me
to find the gradient of this line so
it's 3 divided by 3 which equals 1 meter
per second now I said that this one is
faster because it's got a steeper line
so a steeper gradient let's see if I
could show that using calculations as
well now what I've got to do is I've got
to see how far has this person travel
because again to find the speed I need
to do the distance divided by the time
so this person here they have actually
traveled so it's they started off here
at 3 and they finished up here at 10 so
to find the distance they've traveled
here I need to do 10 take away 3 which
is 7 meters that they've traveled here
okay so what about the time and this
this portion of the graphics
started at eight seconds and went on to
eight ten seconds so to find the amount
of time that's passed I do 810 take away
eight which shows that two seconds have
passed so in order to find the grading
of this line how steep this line is to
find my speed I need to need distance
divided by time so the distance was
seven meters the time was two seconds so
my speed is three point five meters per
second which is faster than this one
here just like I said so a quick recap
speed distance time graph time always
goes on the x axis distance on the y
axis constant speed is shown by a
straight diagonal line like this if an
object is stationary we have a straight
horizontal line like that stationary
just means staying still the steeper the
gradient the fast that the object is
moving and to find the speed we just
need to find the distance and divide it
by the time in or define the gradient
thank you very much